monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs tous étaient volontaires
tous étaient volontaires et ce n'était
pas le cas des autres contingents
nationaux qui débarquèrent le 6 juin
mais les canadiens l'était volontaires
pour partir à l'autre bout du monde pour
défendre la liberté l'état de droit la
démocratie au péril de leur vie
malgré le raid de dieppe et ses 900
morts le 19 août 1942 leur détermination
n'avait pas faibli pendant les mois
d'entraînement qui précédèrent le d-day
les vétérans s'attendait au pire
mais il raconte qu'il voulait y aller
qu'ils étaient impatients
ceux qui ont survécu décrivent un enfer
qui dépassent leur imagination
sous les ordres du général keller la
troisième division canadienne débarque
sur la plage de juno beach dans des
conditions éprouvantes à marée haute
ce qui la rend plus vulnérable aux
obstacles disposés par rohmer
malgré de lourdes pertes ces héros ouvre
une première brèche vers la liberté
la france restera toujours redevable aux
soldats canadiens qui ont participé au
débarquement et à la bataille de
normandie
elle sera toujours redevable aux hommes
et aux femmes de la marine marchande du
canada de la marine royale du canada et
de l'aviation royale du canada
ils se sont illustrés sur tous les
théâtres d'opération et sur tous les
continents
l'effort de guerre canadiens à
contribuer à faire du canada une grande
nation et il a joué un rôle décisif pour
la libération de la france et de
l'europe
nous serons toujours redevable agathe
web lieutenant de la 14e artillerie puis
fondateur du centre juno beach aller aux
majors
ce guerrier exceptionnelle qui après
s'être illustré devait être encore ce
n'aurait encore et nous serons toujours
redevable à gilbert boulanger
ce lieutenant d'aviation qui donnent
aujourd'hui son nom à une école de
courseulles sur mer et à tous ceux que
je ne pourrais pas nommé mais dont
certains sont présents ici parmi nous
aujourd'hui 75 ans après le jour j dunod
beach n'est pas seulement le nom d'une
des cinq plages du débarquement et d'un
remarquable musée qui contribuent au
devoir de mémoire et de réflexion
historique
c'est l'un des noms de notre amitié
franco canadienne qui s' est aussi forgé
comme toute amitié dans les épreuves
nous célébrons cette année les 90 ans
des relations diplomatiques entre nos
deux pays mais nos deux nations nos deux
peuples se connaissent et partagent une
vie commune depuis bien plus longtemps
dans un monde qui s'affolent qui
accélère ses relations leur intensité
leur ancienneté sont précieuses
aujourd'hui les armées de nos deux pays
sont engagés côte à côte en irak dans le
cadre de la coalition internationale qui
luttent contre des ch mais nous payons
aussi d'autres combats à mener ensemble
l'urgence écologique l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes la diversité
culturelle sont autant de grands défis
de civilisation que nous ne pouvons pas
relever seuls ces défis nous allons les
relever ensemble car nous partageons une
histoire et surtout des valeurs nous
allons les relevés grâce à la qualité
des liens qui unissent les dirigeants de
nos deux pays
depuis un an le premier ministre du
canada nous a honoré deux fois d'une
visite en france est le président de la
république française s'est rendue au
canada en juin et dans quelques jours le
canada passera le relais de la
présidence du g7 à la france et nous
allons les relevés car nous sommes nous
aussi volontaire notre jeunesse est
volontaire comme les combattants
canadiens qui débarquèrent le 6 juin
et cette détermination reste la première
condition pour infléchir le cours de
l'histoire
beaucoup ici ont dit qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas imaginer la peur et le courage qu'il
avait fallu à ses hommes pour sortir des
bateaux et affronter cette plage pour
ceux qui viennent après il est difficile
de dire autre chose que mercy mais ce
merci est immense
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]